(typewriter typing)
- [Gary] Sitting here
listening to my music list and
I'm starting to
find a little clarity.
Startin' to understand
why this thing is so hard.
This game of entrepreneurship.
Shit, this game of life.
It's because the real answer is
really found when you're pulling
from opposite directions.
I'm sitting here
laying and saying why,
why, why am I so blessed?
Why is all this
good stuff happening?
And it's because
I'm a contradiction.
Because I've got this funny
juxtaposition where I'm pulling
from opposite directions.
I don't give a fuck what any of
you think about me yet I'll read
every comment and I'll listen to
everything all of you say about
me 'cause I listen.
I talk a fuck load.
I'm always talking.
I'm cutting
people off, I'm talking.
But I'm listening.
I'm listening 24/7.
I'm always patient.
I'm playing the long game but
I'm always quitting things.
Every day trying, testing, not
crippled by stop and starting.
How do I figure that out?
How do I understand when it's
time to give up on something or
when it's time to persevere?
How do I understand, how do
I feel and how I decide when to
listen to somebody's feedback or
to know when they're trolling or
don't give a fuck or
only seeing surface level.
How is this happening?
How am I working 24/7/365 yet it
doesn't feel like I'm working?
How am I always constantly
putting out content and building
my brand yet
never thinking about it
and just living my life?
How am I documenting
instead of creating?
Where is this?
Where is this Zen coming from?
Where is this call
to action coming from?
Why is this
plan working so well?
And how, how do I get all you
youngsters (chuckles) and
when I say youngsters,
I mean the 59-year-old
who hasn't grown up yet,
who hasn't been
willing to look at the world
and it comes from this.
It comes from the most macro.
It's clearing up for me.
I'm starting to see it.
It's understanding that nobody
gives a fuck and that that's
okay and that's
the way it should be.
I live on empathy.
You shouldn't give a fuck.
You got you to worry about.
I'm empathetic to that.
That's the game.
And we're all dealt
with different cards.
We've all got
strengths and weaknesses.
We've got the advantages
and the disadvantages.
Plenty see white
privilege, so do I.
I see privilege from
being from the streets and
having zero and being hungrier.
There's so many different ways.
And of course, some are better
than others at the most macro
but I don't even spend the
time to figure that out.
Because by the time you
figure out if it was fair,
you're fucking finished.
And so, instead of doing that.
I do and I do and I do.
And I'm always planning
and I'm not planning.
And I've always got a game plan
and a strategy and I've always
not got one.
I'm just going off
the hip from intuition,
from learned behavior, from
pattern recognition because
I've been doing
this from the get.
When I was 12, 13,
14, 15, I knew. I did.
It's why I got
those shit grades.
Shout out to everybody who saw
that report card on Instagram.
You know, it's what I do.
And so, as I sit here lay and
look and think and debate and
look out at the ocean
and listen to this music,
it's becoming clearer.
2017 could be a great year.
Not just for me but for you
because as I find clarity,
I'm gonna suffocate negativity.
I'm gonna suffocate excuses.
If you're gonna
be in my community,
you're gonna give up and leave
if you wanna
believe in those things
because I'm gonna
pound it, push it,
press it, harder
than I ever have before.
Because the
truth is I'm thankful.
I'm grateful.
I'm working on
myself 24/7, my goals,
my ambitions, and I'm working
on your goals and
your ambitions 24/7.
That's pulling from
opposite directions.
That's what I do.
That's what I do
harder, stronger,
better than anybody.
Honey Empire, bitches.
Building the biggest
building of all time.
The biggest, best business
of all time like
a fucking tortoise.
Like a slow fucking tortoise.
Chip away every day.
Underestimated
all along the way.
Got my fans who are delusional
and got the rest of the majority
of the market that
doesn't think I can get it.
That doesn't see the behavior
'cause they're thinking 2017,
they're thinking 2019,
they're thinking 2021.
I'm thinking life, bitches.
I'm thinking
mother fuckin' life.
And so I promise you community,
the people that are listening to
this right now,
you've given me
the greatest
fucking gift of all.
You keep your
$500 master classes.
$5,000 masterminds.
You keep your $97 e-books.
You keep that in your pocket.
You do you.
You're gifting me with the
greatest fucking thing on Earth.
Your attention and
your word of mouth.
Every fuckin' time
you tag somebody in
my comments on Instagram.
Every time you share
my story on Snapchat.
Every time you post and share on
Facebook means the world to me.
Every retweet
means the world to me.
That means you're putting me on.
You're co-signing this fucking
journey and for that I will
never take it for granted.
I love you.
Happy 2017.